on lâche fait n'importe quoi vous voyez
je fais n'importe quoi mais par contre
c'est vrai qu'il ya un vrai vrai vrai
plaisir à venir toucher ce clavier
bon maintenant je lui vois deux
inconvénients aux principaux le tout
premier c'est le fait que
[Musique]
pourra parler d'apple fois n'est pas
coutume ça c'est une macbook pro 15
pouces 2011
ça c'est le macbook pro 15 pouces de
2018 ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui on va
pas les comparer ça n'aurait strictement
aucun sens c'est juste pour vous montrer
différence enfin moi je me suis toujours
surpris il ya des années d'évolution il
ya sept ans d'évolution donc ça me
paraît qu'elle est assez normal mais
cette machine là je la trouve hyper
hyper hyper cool elle a vraiment plein
plein plein de points positifs
elle a aussi des projets gatif trophée
c'est très simple rassurez vous on va la
regarder de tous les côtés sous tous les
angles
on va vraiment prendre en considération
tous les points se poser la question aux
seuls macbook pro 2000 kms qui vaut le
coup est ce qu'il faut l'acheter mais je
vous ferai une autre vidéo d'ici
quelques jours pour vous dire quel mac
book acheter macbook pro 13 macbook air
macbook à la fronde à tout ça vraiment
en détail c'est un moment que je vous en
ai parlé malheureusement je n'ai pas
encore trop de temps à faire là je vais
la faire
pour l'instant on se concentre macbook
pro 15 pouces 2018 est-ce qu'il vaut le
coup oui ou non
mais avant toute chose il faut parler
d'un logiciel qui à mon avis un vrai
sens cet ordinateur parce que c'est un
ordinateur professionnel c'est un
logiciel qui est destiné aux
professionnels qui s'appelle pdf
éléments ce pro je sais pas vous mais
moi j'ai souvent galéré avec les pdf
une fois que java pdf était strictement
à pau c'est de pouvoir retravailler
dessus sans galérer ou alors de générer
des fichiers pdf vous pouvez le faire
avec quelques outils mais avec ce
logiciel là ce qui est vraiment bien
c'est vous pouvez exporter un pdf en
othe format image texte word excel et
compagnie je vais vous montrer sa valeur
à partir d'un fichier de textes fichiers
images etc vous pouvez le convertir en
pdf
voilà le logiciel alors vous avez
plusieurs options options principales
vous pouvez modifier un pdf vous pouvez
créer un pdf le créé à partir de pages
html à partir des images ou à partir
d'autres fichiers au format texte
pouvait faire aussi du traitement par
l'on vous pouvez modifier un formulaire
pdf convertir un pdf déjà existants au
format excel word powerpoint et c'est
super cool
et vous pouvez aussi combiner des pdf
créer un seul pdf en combinant plusieurs
types de fichiers dit
les rampes c'est vraiment un outil
extrêmement polyvalent on peut prendre
les pdf les tortiller tous les côtés
créer modifier et exporter en faire ce
qu'on en veut et ça pour le coup croyez
moi c'est franchement très pratique
je vous montre un premier exemple je
veux créer un fichier pdf à partir d'une
image je clique ici je vais ouvrir le
dernier télé loisirs dans lequel ge à
paris bon je vous passe le côté mise en
page vous faire vraiment beaucoup de
choses à ajouter des images du texte
recadrés physique enfin vous pouvez
faire tout ce que vous voulez une fois
vous avez fait tout votre travail là
dessus
vous allez donc fichiers vous
enregistrer directement en pdf vous
allez dans vos documents vous retrouvez
votre fichier pdf là franchement c'est
hyper cool autre exemple pratique j'ai
déjà un pdf et je veux le modifier
j'avais donc m'ouvrir un pdf là par
exemple j'ai le règlement d'un concours
l'ajax est à tous mon texte que je peux
modifier très très très très très
facilement modalités participation je
viens et je modifie avec un e c'est
mieux voilà et voyez c'est hyper simple
de la même manière on suit je vais là
j'enregistre et ça va me ré enregistrer
directement mon pdf
donc ça c'est franchement hyper cool
voyais au final je monte des
fonctionnalités un peu basique l'idc
vous pouvez tout est dit est extrêmement
facilement mais si je rentre dans le
détail ça va nous faire une vidéo
carrément entière là l'idée c'est de
vous présenter et croyez-moi il
franchement cool s'il vous intéresse je
vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description
bon maintenant on retourne sur cette
jolie machine si vous me connaissez si
vous avez l'habitude vous savez comment
les mac
j'aime bien les utiliser en décoration
que la décoration se casse pas la gueule
lui date de notre temps où mes bronches
de garde en souvenir et voyez comme ça
sous cet angle là il a une certaine
ergonomie il est très joli bon
aujourd'hui on va plutôt parler de celui
là il est franchement hyper hyper classe
et vous allez voir il a énormément de
points positifs
d'un point de vue purement ergonomique
c'est vrai que la machine est super
super belle extrêmement fine ça c'est
vraiment un truc que j'adore sur cet
ordinateur vous avez donc déjà deux
ports thunderbolt 3 usb type c'est une
petite prise jack qui est conservée ici
ça c'est cool absolument rien d'autre et
de l'autre côté pareil c'est extrêmement
minimaliste deux ports thunderbolt 3 usb
type c sinon il n'y a absolument rien du
tout très fin très discret très léger
c'est vraiment une très très très jolie
machine qui a vraiment été revus
corrigés sur ce modèle de 2010
avec pas mal d'améliorations par rapport
au modèle de 2017 et encore plus par
rapport aux vrais de 2016
déjà la première chose qu'on voit là
dessus c'est d'abord fin on a vraiment
des bords qui sont très très faim mais
qui sont pas non plus complètement
invisible ce qui fait que ça permet
quand même à l'écran de se détacher de
ce que vous allez avoir derrière ça
reste quand même très sympa vous avez si
une caméra hd elle fait le job pas trop
trop lui en demander c'est pas des
points forts de cette bécane vous avez
un écran de 15,4 pouces et un écran
retina séduit ps et du lcd 2880 pas
mille 800 pixels à 220 pixels par pouce
vous avez un écran trou tonnes le trou
tonnes sa part vers votre écran
s'adapter complètement aux conditions de
luminosité de la pièce dans laquelle
vous êtes ça va complètement optimiser
votre écran notamment pour reposer votre
regard et éviter quand en fin de journée
vous les yeux dans lapin qui atteint de
myxomatose en termes de spec de
performance pure et dure vous avez un
intel core i7 cadencé jusqu'à 2,2
gigahertz et jusqu'à 4 1 gigahertz en
mode turbo vous avez six coeurs g 16
giga de ram et un ssd de 256 giga alors
bon repas grimpeuse des questions de
stockage pour faire vraiment hyper
attention lorsqu'on va choisir sa bécane
parce que si vous partez dès le départ
sur un ssd qui n'est pas assez grand
vous risquez franchement nous avoir les
doigts très rapidement et 256 giga pour
moi c'est largement insuffisant le
minimum ses 512 giga mais tout de suite
ça fait un petit peu augmenté l'addition
soit modèle 15 pouces vous avez un gpu à
part du cpu
c'est une radio pro 5 155 x avec les 4
gigas de mémoire dédiée en termes de
puissance je trouve franchement très
très bien ça dépend bien sûr ce que vous
allez en faire ça on en reparlera
également après on parlera des options
vous allez pouvoir rajouter en termes de
mémoire vive en termes de ssd en termes
de puissance qu'on peut monter jusqu'à
un intel core i9 ça va complètement
dépendre de vos besoins dépendre de
votre métier
mais tel qu'il est là en l'état je te
rassure en usage courant pour aller 81 %
des personnes c'est vraiment une
excellente machine gros point fort cette
année c'est le clavier alors le clavier
papillon on a beaucoup entendu parler il
a eu beaucoup de déboires là il a été
revu et corrigé notamment rajoutant du
silicone en dessous des touches ce qui
apporte deux points très positifs
le tout premier ça va empêcher les
impuretés de passer en dessous et de
bloquer les touches qui fait que vous
touche
elle marche bien qu'il deuxième point
très positif surtout que vous avez un
clavier complètement silencieux ça c'est
vrai que ça fait franchement franchement
du bien on lâche et n'importe quoi
vous voyez je fais n'importe quoi mais
par contre c'est vrai qu'il ya un vrai
vrai vrai plaisir à venir toucher ce
clavier ça c'est franchement un vrai
plaisir de poires manipuler ce clavier
la qualité vraiment là il ya un vrai
retour de touche pourtant vous avez tous
qu'ils sont complètement plate c'est
extrêmement profilées ça doit vraiment
rajouter au design est vraiment finir de
petit peu ce produit et ça c'est
vraiment top alors il ya un deuxième
point est très important ici c'est le
trackpad le trackpad il est complètement
hallucinant faire ça c'est pas tout
nouveau ça fait déjà quelques bonnes
années que apple ou sans les frais de
padt qui sont complètement fous furieux
là vous avez un truc qui est juste
gigantesque en plus d'avoir vraiment de
la place d'être extrêmement précis vous
avez le 3d touch connaissait throne of
change rien vous apprendre regarder
j'appuie taxe a un vrai sens c'est
vraiment cool ça c'est un des points
très très fort de ce mac parce que il ya
une vraie maîtrise d'apple sur son
clavier
il ya une vraie maîtrise d'apple sur son
trackpad et en plus de ça vous avez
encore un autre point qui franchement
génial c'est la touch barre bon la touch
bah c'est pas le truc qui vient
d'arriver dans le monde d'apple mais par
contre c'est vrai que c'est franchement
très pratique et puis qu à force on
finit vraiment par lui trouver des
usages
vous avez beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de possibilités et ça
dépend complètement des différentes
applications
que ce soit bien sûr pour régler le
volume pour mettre la lecture pour
régler tout ce que vous voulez là je
vous demande vraiment des trucs de base
mais en fonction des logiciels sur
lesquels vous allez être vous allez
pouvoir faire beaucoup de choses pour le
montage c'est cool pour une navigation
sur internet c'est tout aussi cool
exemple tout bête première anglais sur
le site d'apple deuxième onglet je suis
sur facebook et bien sûr les retrouver
tous les deux directement ici dans ma
tête je bats je peux passer de l'un à
l'autre très très très facilement voyez
ça c'est vraiment cool
c'est hyper intuitif et c'est un exemple
parmi tant d'autres qui montrent
vraiment que cette tâche bas on y trouve
vraiment d
intérêt très spécifiques je ne veux ni
rock créé un nouvel onglet là je choisis
je navigue ensuite ce que je veux ouvrir
par rapport à mai raccourci que je vais
avoir directement ici allez qu'est ce
que je vais mettre par exemple up
wikipédia ça va m'ouvrir wikipedia là je
vais en a ajouté un autre claque je
clique
allez hop pop un petit google sans
google clame de ce bar quitté au début
un peu gadget a vraiment aujourd'hui un
vrai sens et une vraie utilité sur ces
machines
alors vous allez voir pour du montage
enfin michael pro c'est vraiment
pratique sur plein de logiciels ça
devient très pratique et ça c'est
vraiment cool
sur ce modèle en plus vous avez du
bluetooth 5.0 vous avez syrie
l'autonomie en ce sens la machine est
franchement excellentes ça va dépendre
complètement de vos usages
si vous passez beaucoup de temps sur
logic à faire des montages si vous
travaillez sous photoshop que vous avez
plein de charisme mais nous sommes
beaucoup de puissance ou fait de la 3d
qui a vraiment venir chercher de la
ressource
la machine derrière va encaisser par
contre l'autonomie va baisser si par
contre c'est de la bureautique
ça ira tout de suite beaucoup mieux
c'est vraiment pas du tout une machine
qui va vous décevoir
autre point qui est franchement énorme
cette machine c'est l'audio les
haut-parleurs c'était ici de chaque côté
du clavier et franchement ça envoie du
bois
c'est très bien
[Musique]
et l'or
il ya beaucoup de puissance le son est
de qualité c'est franchement cool une
belle spatialisation peut dire que là
dessus aussi il ya un vrai bon boulot de
fait de la part d'apple
maintenant il ya une prise jack à on va
l'utiliser ça serait quand même dommage
de laisser ça de côté
[Applaudissements]
c'est énorme
le volume que vous avez là dedans alors
le but et pâturant complètement sourd
mais c'est vrai que ça marche très très
bien
cette machine à d'un point de vue audio
d'un point de vue multimédia c'est
vraiment un excellent d'ordinateurs
portables bon maintenant je lui vois
deux inconvénients principaux le tout
premier c'est le fait que vous n'ayez
que 2 du port thunderbolt 3 usb type c
de chaque côté vous allez absolument
rien d'autre ce qui fait que en termes
de compatibilité
même avec les produits d'apple c'est pas
terrible tout simplement parce que
lorsque vous allez acheter le dernier
ipad pro il se connecte en usb type
c'est donc là usb type cds bêtise c'est
ça n'a pas de problème par contre si
vous avez un iphone avec l'ordinateur et
avec les iphone vous n'avez pas
d'adaptateur port lightning vers usb
type c'est ça il va falloir aller
l'acheter par vous même ça fait un petit
peu râler ou surtout quand on connaît le
prix des accessoires apple donc ce qui
est très important pour contrer tous à
m'acheter un dock là je prends un
exemple c'est un petit dock de chez
targus qui marche très bien ce qui va
avoir très très très positif et ce qui
est vraiment cool et du coup c'est aussi
un peu le point fort cette machine c'est
la face son point faible et sont encore
vous connais votre petit 2 vous allez le
brancher directement hop en usb type c
est avec ça vous allez pouvoir faire
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
choses vous allez pouvoir avoir par
exemple bien déjà deux ports usb type ah
ça c'est cool
retrouvez notre port usb type c si
toutefois vous en aviez encore besoin
vous allez pouvoir brancher de
l'internet et hop même de l'autre côté
avoir une sortie à vga pour un moniteur
standards du hdmi ça c'est cool
donc ça c'est vraiment un accessoire qui
pour moi aujourd'hui sur cette machine
comme ça est un indispensable et qui par
contre malheureusement n'est pas du tout
fourni d'origine par apple
par contre ce qui est franchement énorme
lorsque ça marche c'est que votre
ordinateur devient une station de
travail qui est complètement
hallucinante avec 4 ports thunderbolt 3
usb tu sais vous pouvez franchement en
faire déjà dans le premier pour imaginer
mettre un disque dur qui va travailler
très rapidement notamment
pour la vidéo pour la sauvegarde du
travail en direct ça c'est un très très
très bon point le deuxième point c'est
une fois branché par exemple sur les
deux autres ports thunderbolt roi des
moniteurs quatre cas ça c'est cool donc
là vous mettez deux moniteurs pour
bosser votre disque dur d'un côté et
puis après on pouvait mettre un dock de
l'autre côté pour avoir du port usb type
a pour avoir tout ce que vous voulez
c'est franchement génial c'est à la fois
un point négatif un point de regret mais
à la fois quand on y réfléchit bien un
vrai gros point positif entrepôt de
regrets là dessus c'est le fait de ne
pas avoir d' écran tactile alors il ya
peut-être que moi que ça choque quand je
vois des pc qui ont des écrans tactiles
qui coûte beaucoup moins cher que ça
mais je me dis que c'est dommage
qu'apple aurait pu aller dessus cet
arrêté de bien d'avoir un ordinateur
tactile le pouvoir piloter son mac os
récement avait dessus de pouvoir
travailler avec un stylet directement
sur photoshop dessus s'en repaître
vraiment cool ou alors faire un montage
pourquoi pas sauf à dire que trop de
pouvoir bouger des choses à la marque je
sais pas il pourrait y avoir vraiment un
sens quand je vois que du produit de
chez dell des produits de chez asus vous
avez sur le haut de gamme des écrans
tactiles
je pense à toujours dommage que apple
soit pas encore allé dessus alors après
peut-être est-ce pour ne pas
complexifier les gammes il nous sort des
ipad pro qui coûtent chers qui sont
tactiles vont plus travailler avec un
style études sont vraiment très très
très performant
est ce que c'est vraiment pour des
tâches et les deux produits avec le
macbook pro vous allez avoir de la
puissance de la performance plus que ce
que vous ne pourrez avoir dans un ipad
pro donc notamment pour faire de la 3d
du montage même du graphisme et en face
à nay pas de trop qui lui est vraiment
destiné au côté graphique à la tablette
graphique
je sais pas je sais pas trop quoi en
penser
bon ça c'est un point de détail ça
n'empêchera pas en tout cas moi d'aller
sur cette typologie de produits parce
que je trouve vraiment bien mais c'est
vrai que ça aurait pu être un vrai plus
sur cette bécane peut-être pour les
années à venir
et maintenant parlons de ce qui nous
intéresse tous c'est le tarif parce que
cette jolie petite bête
elle a quand même un certain coût on va
pas se mentir c'est cher là c'est apple
ça coûte de l'argent
je vais vous donner le tarif a rejeté
par qui par coeur c'est dans mes petites
notes alors ce modèle là à ses little
core i7 et danse à 2,2 gigahertz 256
gigaoctets de stockage 16 giga de ram
coûte de 1799 euros
c'est franchement déjà à très bon prix
moi quand je vois que le mien alors
apprécié pareil en
à 2011 il ya franchement sept ans qu'il
ne sais pas mais je crois que j'ai payé
qu'une extension de garantie à 2000
euros et d'écouté 1700 et quelques roses
neuf c'est à dire que entre ce modèle là
et ce modèle là il ya mille euros
d'écart c'est pas ce qui s'est passé en
sept ans donc j'imagine même pas dans
sept ans combien vont coûter ces
machines là parce que ça va continuer
sur cette lancée voilà ça reste quand
même un certain budget après il ya de la
peur
après il ya un ssd à la base moi j'aime
pas un ssd je les lis après bon il faut
aussi comparer ce qui est comparable
mais c'est vrai que je trouve quand même
que ça reste très très très cher et si
vous allez sur notre modèle c'est à dire
un état core i7 cadencé jusqu'à 2,6
gigahertz 16 gigaoctets de ram 512 giga
de stockage 3299 euros
c'est quand même un certain prix alors
après les options et c'est là un petit
poule au truc s'envole si vous voulez
passer carrément sur intel core i9 ça ne
coûtera plus de 480 euros
si vous voulez passer sur 32 gigas de 16
giga de plus 480 euros au lieu d'avoir
une rébellion pro 5 155 x voulait passer
sur modèle 560 x + 120 euros et par
contre là où les prix s'envolent c'est
sur le prix du ssd sur le stockage là ça
devient complètement fou
ça sent 12 giga de stockage à la base de
256 plus 240 euros 1 tera plus 720 euros
de terra plus 1680 euros et cap terra
plus 4000 80 euros est ce que vous êtes
24 terra je suis pas sûr après on peut
toujours dire qu'on va passer sur un
disque externe en thunderbolt roi ça
peut aussi le faire
il peut y avoir un vrai intérêt mais je
pense néanmoins les gens restent
intimement convaincu qu acheter un
macbook pro en 256 giga vous allez être
très rapidement limité en terme de
stockage en termes de photos de tout ce
que vous voulez de vidéos vous risquez
franchement de vous en mordre les doigts
je serais vous dès le départ je
n'hésiterai pas à rajouter 240 euros on
est plus de 140 euros près je plaisante
bien sûr
pour terminer à qui se destine ce
macbook pro des professionnels des
utilisateurs exigeants qui dit pro moi
je pense surtout à des infographistes à
des gens qui travaillent dans le domaine
de la vidéo et des gens qui bossent dans
la 3d pour vraiment avoir une machine
complètement complètement complètement
polyvalente avec beaucoup de puissance
assez peu les étudiants pour les
étudiants n'y a plus sur un magot
au caire qui va coûter moins cher un
modèle 13 pouces modèle 15 pouces ça
reste quand même le modèle le plus haut
de gamme dans cette typologie machine
est forcément celle qu'il a coûté le
plus cher et ça s'adresse également aux
mac lovers à tous ceux qui aiment apple
et qui forcément veulent des ordis
veulent un 15 pouces mais veulent un 15
pouces sur un macbook pro est forcément
à ce prix là vous allez en avoir pour
votre argent
et quant à vous dites moi ce que vous en
pensez est ce que vous le trouvez bien
ce macbook pro 2018 est ce que vous
pourriez vous laisser tenter
est ce que vous vous êtes laissé tenter
et si vous êtes laissé tenter qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
est ce que vous êtes satisfait
satisfaites ou alors carrément déçu moi
je trouve qu'il devrait belle avancée là
dessus l'acteur joue bach est vraiment
cool le clavier est vraiment et
améliorait que ça a été vraiment enfants
qui était critiqué le trackpad reste
toujours très très bon on pourrait aller
plus loin encore au niveau de l'écran
notamment avec du tactile on pourrait
encore améliorer un peu tout ça mais je
trouve que déjà aujourd'hui cette
machine comme elle est là en terme de
performance elle est bien dans mon
autonomie ali bien en termes de qualité
générale c'est vraiment une superbe et
cannes et je vous dis vous invite à vous
abonner parce que dans quelques jours si
vous sortir un guide qu'elles n'aillent
book acheté en 2018 voire 2019 parce que
maintenant on n'est plus qu'à quelques
jours près d'ici là je vous invite à
aller voir aussi à ma playlist pour
découvrir tous les ordis du moment pc
nac comme ça vous pourrez vous faire un
avis un petit peu général sur ce qui se
fait en ce moment
et puis d'ici là soyez ça je vous
embrasse portez vous bien ciao